[Music]
my first project was focused on actually
trying to get more human-like behavior
in Minecraft which was leveraging a
scripted agent and very few human
demonstrations so given like 33 human
demonstrations and an existing scripted
agent the question was how can we
incorporate some sort of learning into
the agent not to necessarily make it
perform better but to make it more
engaging and interesting and hopefully
more human-like you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen Hughes
Inga in 2018 Microsoft launched the
Microsoft AI residency program a
year-long expanded research experience
designed to give recent graduates in a
variety of fields the opportunity to
work alongside prominent researchers at
MSR on cutting edge AI technologies to
solve real world problems dr. Brian
troll was one of them a newly minted PhD
in computer science from Vanderbilt
University dr. Birol was among the
inaugural cohort of AI residents who
spent a year working on machine learning
in game environments and is on the pod
to talk about it today dr. Perl gives us
an overview of the work he did and the
experience he had as a Microsoft AI
resident
talks about his passion for making
complex concepts easier and more
accessible to novices and young learners
and tells us how growing up on a dairy
farm in rural Minnesota helped prepare
him for a life in computer science
solving some of the toughest problems in
AI that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Bryan Grohl welcome to the podcast
thanks happy to be here so this one's
gonna be different you're not actually
in microsoft research proper you're part
of a really interesting new program it's
called Microsoft's AI residency program
and you're part of the very first cohort
right so 2018 it started the first year
you're just finishing up yep before we
begin our regularly scheduled
programming give us a bit of an overview
about the residency program tell us what
it is what's cool about it and actually
why you did it
sure so the residency program is a
year-long fixed-term position where you
come in and you work on two different
six-month projects and the applicants
come from a variety of different
backgrounds a lot of them with the
computer science background but some
even from like quantum physics and some
people with more than NLP background
some people with ethics and psychology
and a cognitive psych so there's a
variety of different backgrounds and all
priority of different degree levels then
people come in and get to work on all
sorts of different projects for again
two six-month periods right it's its
first instantiation of a residency I
when I hear that I think of medical
residences right you are a doctor but a
different guy yeah yeah I don't usually
operate we said try not exactly exactly
I mean there are some things that make a
lot of sense about doing a residency I
would suspect that one of the benefits
is certainly that if they have people
here working on research projects with a
lot of people at MSR and making a lot of
these really great connections and then
they move to like some other product
team or sticker on a Microsoft or even
if they return back to like academia to
in some cases pursue a PhD in other
cases come on directly as faculty yeah
it certainly facilitates a lot of these
relationships and collaborations either
within again product teams and MSR or
potentially within other academic
institutions and Emma sorry well at the
beginning of every podcast I asked my
guests what gets you up in the morning
you're more the beginning of your career
than most of the people that I have in
the booth so I'm going to tweak the
question a bit and ask you what's on
your research roadmap what kinds of
questions excite you and if you could
encapsulate it succinctly
what's the big goal of your research
yeah that's a good question in the past
I've done things with like educational
visual programming environments and
trying to make more advanced and complex
topics more easily accessible by younger
users or young learners in some cases
and I've also done some work in like
related spaces around like developer
tools and again just trying to see how
you can take advanced concepts and make
them something that people can not just
like interact with had a high level but
hopefully have a deep and rich
engagement in so that you can really
leverage it for whatever sort of task or
problem they really care about so that's
definitely a recurring theme and I have
found that when I work on different
projects a lot of times I end up coming
back to this question like even if I'm
not trying to target some like end user
or developer or make something
accessible I always find myself
wondering first of all how could I solve
whatever problem I'm working on and then
one step back like how could I get to
that information that I need to be able
to figure out or solve whatever problem
I'm working on and then like how could I
do this easier I often find myself
falling into the same train of thought
even when I'm the only person doing it
of like I really want to be confident
that things are working the way that I
think they are are the questions come in
a variety of different forms depending
upon specifically what I'm working on
yeah but it can vary from how can I
really better understand this problem so
I can figure out a solution to like how
can i really be sure that what I think
is happening is actually happening and
when I start going to those types of
questions I always find myself naturally
wondering like is there a better way
that I can like fundamentally approach
this so that's an easier task to solve
or to be confident in my solution will
get to the laziness business later
because I think that's an underrated
quality for people well let's talk for a
minute about the graduate work you did
since you are a what I would call newly
minted PhD and your work is really fresh
so give us an overview of the work you
did to get your degree and tell us a
little of how that's informed what
you're doing now
sure so I finished up my PhD a year ago
at Vanderbilt and I was working on
making distributed computing concepts
more accessible to kids so basically we
wanted to extend programming
environments that are meant to have a
really low like threshold so that kids
can get started programming really
easily so like more specifically I was
focused on like box based program
environments so you might be familiar
with like scratch or snap now my work
was trying to empower students using
these environments with the abilities to
build distributed applications so this
would include potentially fun and
hopefully more engaging things like chat
applications or multiplayer games or
like it's really the sky's the limit
hopefully you can give them the tools
where they can really express their
creativity and learn something cool in
the process so I think it's cool when
you can appeal to other demographics by
making it much more grounded so it feels
applicable and relevant yeah well also
trying to make it more social by giving
them the power to build the network
enabled applications so they can
actually make these games multiplayer or
make chat applications and then start to
reason about the natural things that
often come up I've been in classes
before where I've introduced her things
like a client-server architecture one
that comes to mind is I was working with
a group of eighth graders and I
introduced the client-server
architecture as we made a chat
application during class and it's funny
how concepts come up supernaturally that
are really huge like they were doing a
distributed denial-of-service
unintentionally immediately like I mean
it makes sense you have a classroom of
students and I set up a server and they
can all see things and naturally you get
some trolls in the audience just find
out that or they can use this loop
that's just an infinite loop and just
keep sending messages to the server and
then we have to step back and talk about
how do we detect spam and how would we
start filtering this stuff out but the
thing that I I want to emphasize about
this example it's not necessarily that
these kids were learning to DDoS but
that these concepts come up organically
in a way that they can get their hands
on it and then start reasoning about how
to solve this problem and different
techniques and then hopefully then
evaluating the different types of
solutions that they might come up with
so did they even know that what they
were doing had a name pretty flexible
when you're doing things like this
because so the class can go a lot of
different ways it's too funny
well how did that work play out and do
you find it has legs and building on it
yes so that work is a continuing project
at Vanderbilt are a lot of different
projects and efforts that are building
on top of it for example a year ago we
had two one week-long summer camps that
were sponsored by NSA now we're focusing
on cyber secure
early in the context of cyber-physical
systems so more concretely where they
were given robots and then we started
introducing them to like programming
because we couldn't assume prior
programming experience so we first tried
to do some basic introduction to
programming and then I started
introducing them to programming on like
robots and then after that started
getting into cybersecurity questions so
essentially grounding us a little bit
more we had a classroom of students and
we had like a collection of robots and
rather than a lot of the existing
robotic programming platforms we didn't
like have a single computer have to be
physically connected or associated with
a specific robot it was more like we had
a sandbox of students who could interact
with a group of robots and they were all
assigned a specific one but this means
that kids will start trolling each other
and trying to control each other's
robots and things like that and I think
it's great because this means that in
the way that we design instead of the
environment we can do it in a way that
facilitates the I guess natural
development of some of these sorts of
concepts so I encryption comes up pretty
naturally then if we're like well people
keep trying to control my robot and I
want it to drive but you're gonna stop
exactly and then we start talking about
code breaking in this adversarial nature
of cybersecurity lends itself very
nicely to a curriculum - as in the sense
that you can introduce one sort of very
natural initial fix and then how you can
counter that and then how you counter
the counter and and you can continue
developing along that route and you have
students who are changing the encryption
on the robot really frequently and
trying to prevent replay attacks and all
sorts of fun topics
[Music]
well we talked a little bit about the
residency program in general but I want
to talk about what you did while you
were here let's plunge right into your
year at the Microsoft ai residency
program yep so I worked with the
reinforcement learning team and I was
working on machine learning in games so
rather than some of the machine learning
where they're trying to essentially
replace a human with an AI we were
focused more on how can we leverage
machine learning to be like
complementary to the game development
process so not necessarily just trying
to use them as a sandbox to show that we
can learn complex tasks but say like how
can we actually benefit games from
incorporating machine learning either
into like the development process or
some sort of aspect of the game that
complements it later so I was working
mostly with a couple people in the RL
team here in Redmond but also
collaborated a bit with a bunch of
researchers out in Cambridge we're also
working on this UK yeah Cambridge UK yes
I've over again a similar effort so my
first project was focused on actually
trying to get more human-like behavior
in minecraft which was leveraging a
scripted agent and very few human
demonstrations so given like 33 human
demonstrations and an existing scripted
agent the question was how can we
incorporate some sort of learning into
the agent not to necessarily make it
perform better but to make it more
engaging and interesting and hopefully
more human like that go we did find some
pretty positive results and we were able
to create a hybrid agent that did
demonstrate more of the behaviors that
we thought were interesting and engaging
from the human perspective so like
contextual decision-making as well as
you saw similar high level strategies
exhibited by this hybrid agent where I
was able to learn the strategies just
from the human demonstration so those
aspects of it were very positive so
there is a lot of flexibility in taking
some of these data driven approaches and
we were hoping that we could be able to
when defining a new agent in this game
used scripting for the parts that make
sense to write code for and then use
data for the parts that makes sense to
use demonstrations for right there are
other aspects or ways to view it that
are less practical and more trying to
think about some of the fundamental
challenges and some of the fundamental
challenges in this context would be that
this scripted agent gave us a
hierarchical policy where we could
replace in our context meta controller
so basically the part of the
that was picking the high level like
goals of the agent in this game and you
can assume that humans have a similar
type of implicit hierarchical policy in
other words they're not just thinking
like whether or not they should move
forward and left like without any
concern for a high-level plan like like
they're thinking like oh I should go and
grab this thing or interact easily
exactly there's some sort of high-level
strategy now one of the challenges in
this case was that we were just trying
to learn the meta controller via
imitation from the human demonstrations
and the low-level policy of the scripted
agent was well of course scripted so
that meant that that part wasn't able to
learn at all so now the challenging part
is that we know that the lower level
policy things like pathfinding and such
might not match with what the humans are
doing but we still want to be able to
imitate which makes it challenging
because you don't want to try to imitate
at a lower level then like you can't
just look at like different states of
the game and just try to compare them
between like the hybrid agent which are
trying to again train the meta
controller and the human demonstrations
because given the same goal they might
have different ways of achieving that
goal
so really you really want to try to
essentially predict the humans intention
and then try to incorporate the humans
intention into the meta controller so it
tries to predict what a human would try
to do given the state that it seen so
far and then reuse the scripted part to
actually like achieve this intention of
this sub goal that it thinks that the
human would have so it's a tricky
problem well what kinds of research
thinking does that inspire I mean you've
got to then figure out okay how am I
gonna do this how are we going to take
what's natural up here and put it in the
software so one of the biggest questions
if we're thinking about trying to
approach or tackle this question is a
bit of like how can you actually find
some sort of signal in the data that we
can actually use to train the meta
controller and in this case it's not
just some signal I guess it's really the
right signal so I gave the example
already of if you have chose tried to
look at states we could try to imagine
just trying also two different
possibilities in the meta controller and
seeing which one gets closest to what
the human was doing but the problem
there is that you start to like
encapsulate I guess the things like path
finding and stuff which will just
introduce noise but
isn't really what you're trying to
measure because you could imagine that
now this is usually easier to explain
with a whiteboard but you could imagine
that that you see some human taking some
arc to whatever its goal is and there's
all sorts of different like entities or
sub goals that are possible on the
screen and you could imagine that you
have some sort of scripted agent that
just goes directly to its sub goal now
if you knew what the person's intention
was the expected behavior would be an
arc in the human demonstration and a
direct path in the resulting hybrid
agent but if you're not careful in the
only looking at the low-level States you
would try to force the hybrid agent to
take an arc and you might be able to do
this by picking all sorts of garbage sub
goals really quickly to make it move
directly on a little bit to the right
and a little bit forward and a little
bit back to the lab and kind of create
this arc shape but that's really not at
all what you want then it'll be
especially problematic when we start
looking at different humans it's not
that all humans share the same path
finding logical levels sub policies so
so it'll get even more complicated and
difficult to try to learn so the type of
thinking for this project really
required you to kind of step back and
try to really understand fundamentally
what sort of approaches could be used to
try to learn really what we care about
here which isn't immediately obvious how
to isolate the aspects of the human
demonstrations that we care about in the
context of this hybrid agent in those
parts got a little hairy so another
thing you did during the residency was
extend the results of the work that you
did at the outset so what questions were
left on answer what prompts did you sort
of gather from what you learned and how
did you go about trying to answer them
with follow-up research sure so I mean I
think this is a pretty standard process
in a lot of research where you want to
try to make something work in a complex
environment and you might make some
compromises on the way and then you want
to step back and see how many of those
you can fix or resolve or weaken or
loosen so one of the things that I've
been working on during the course of the
second project has been trying to I
guess relax some of the requirements
that we had from the first project now
specifically one of the ways that we
derived signal in the first project was
to look at the human demonstrations and
leverage a labeling function so a
concept that's been used to drive
provision for large unlabeled data sets
to drive like weak supervision so you
might get like these noisy labels and
things like that but hopefully given
enough data you can still learn
something meaningful in this context now
for the first project I wrote a labeling
function and just took the most I guess
direct approach to trying to get signal
like in this case I tried to encode the
heuristic that regardless if it's a
human or an AI we can probably infer
what its goal is based on what it's
going to move most toward in the future
so I had a labeling function that would
look ahead into the future and then look
at what the human moves most directly
toward and then it would say that this
is probably a decent approximation of
what their sub goal was so we can do
this for every state and then even
though there might be some noise and the
labels we can hopefully learn something
meaningful enough that it reasonably
approximates what the human's
intentional is the thing that I didn't
like about it was that that means that
our labeling function has to have a good
heuristic and a good idea of what the
human was going toward and especially if
we're gonna apply this into other
domains it might be harder for any
arbitrary state to be giving me a good
approximation of what the humans trying
to do now and even though it doesn't
have to be a perfect approximation there
are some sort of domains where this
could be really challenging so what I've
been trying to do during the second
portion of the project was relax that to
the point where rather than provide an
approximate signal or an approximate
label for all states see if we can just
go through and if there's a state we
really are confident about we label that
one in other words this is really just
trying to ground the humans intentions
in the context of Minecraft based on
some interaction so it's reasonable to
say that if the player picks up the
psyche some item they were probably
trying to if they attack tombi or some
some sort of entity that was probably
their goal so instead of worrying about
over the course of five seconds while
it's doing battle with a bunch of
different enemies and interacting with
things like picking up weapons and
attacking other entities in the game
rather than trying to predict the label
at each point and trying to disambiguate
one exactly or what exact frame does it
start moving from one enemy to another
or things like that or when exactly does
it start to retreat and or when is it
just collecting itself to attack again
rather than trying to disambiguate the
labels for those states using a labeling
function so directly we just tried to
relax it to the point where when we see
something that we're confident about
like again an interaction in the game
we'll just label those and then see if
using this much more
set of labels we can still get
meaningful results for predicting humans
intention the idea here is that if we're
able to do some sort of like pre
training and bias the network on some
related tasks then maybe using these
parser labels we can just kind of fine
tune the original weights which were
again trained on some similar tasks like
that could be predicting like distances
or just something that's learning more
of what the heuristic that the labeling
functional is encoding we could instead
just bias some of these suspicions that
we have through their use of training it
on related tasks and then fine-tune it
on this smaller set of labels that we
can trust with much higher confidence
because we actually see some sort of
game interaction okay
well circle back to the laziness issue
in some ways laziness is the great
motivator for invention and we talked
about this as sort of a recurring theme
in the work you're choosing to tackle
making complex things easier for people
especially for novices and non-experts
and more accessible in the process so
can you expand on that just a little bit
why it's important to you sure I mean I
can never help the irony when I find
myself sitting at the computer and doing
repeated tasks especially when a huge
part of programming is about automation
I mean I guess a little bit more maybe
philosophically I don't really like when
the tools that I'm working with get in
the way of the problem I'm solving like
they should really be complimentary and
I shouldn't be spending time trying to
like I don't know wrangle or fight with
the tools themselves
I guess that ideology kind of pushes me
towards like or gives me very little
patience for when I'm doing something or
some repeated task manually over and
over and definitely pushes me towards
finding some way to not only remove or
reduce any repetition but also see if
there's a way that the tools can really
hopefully get out of the way so that the
person can actually try to reason about
and understand the problem that they're
actually trying to solve I don't want to
confuse this with trying to find like a
silver bullet I've run into this a bit
actually in grad school when people
sometimes would debate about like visual
programming versus like textual
programming languages or like whether or
not blocks based programming is like a
real programming language which which I
don't know I mean personally I feel like
there's syntax the semantics it falls
under the category of program
even though most the time the point that
they're making is really I do use it for
like industrial grade applications but
snow the ones that I've used in the ones
that I've written there I think their
strength is in making it easy to access
some of these complex topics and
concepts and be able to learn really
valuable things but I'm not recommending
that we go in write performance critical
applications in these languages but I do
think that it's funny when people kind
of get this idea of it having to be one
or the other because I think really the
best set of tools are ones that play
well with each other I guess what I
should say is it's not like every
carpenter starts with just like a hammer
you don't like I mean tries to build a
house entirely with a hammer
exactly you need a huge tool set and you
need to make sure these all like
complement each other and work together
nicely well I can't let any podcast go
by without asking what could possibly go
wrong and this is actually my thing cuz
I'm that person in eighth grade who
would have tried to hack someone else's
robot just cuz you know do we all use
our powers for good some of us use them
for evil just say it
not full-on evil but just you know yeah
yes certainly anyway so is there
anything about the work that you're
doing that keeps you up at night any
potential downside and if so how could
you from the get-go build in safeguards
to mitigate that yes that's a really
good question I mean a lot of things
that I really liked about the work that
I've done in the past and this gets a
little bit more into my I know many
preferences and ideologies about like
software and ecosystems and community
and all that good stuff but I really
like when these sorts of tools and
concepts can be really accessible to
people across the board you know like I
in undergrad I was a math major and I
got a teaching licensure and my first
teaching placement was at a school in
need of assistance so like a very large
minority demographic some of them come
from it would come from like really
rough childhoods and really unsafe home
environments and things like then one of
the things that I really enjoy about a
lot of the work that I did
at Vandy and trying to make these more
complex topics
and some of the things that I really
like about open source software in
general is this idea of basically being
able to give people the resources or the
abilities to be able to get involved and
to learn a lot without any regard to
like a lot of the social issues that can
get in the way now that being said a lot
of the work that I've been doing has
been publicly available it's free if
people want to use it they can just use
it but this does go hand in hand with
potential misuse now in my case since
I'm mostly trying to empower people to
be able to do things that they couldn't
do before it's not necessarily a social
platform so there are different types of
risks and issues but it is challenging I
mean just because you teach people some
of these like cybersecurity concepts it
doesn't really guarantee that they won't
try to be on the hacker side rather than
I think the white hat side I haven't
really built in any safeguards right now
I'm concerned about taking away from the
people who could really benefit from it
and you already have enough challenges
so that makes it really challenging I
always hope that these types of things
can be addressed with ideally just more
of developing like a positive culture
and community and people buying into
that because you hope that people aren't
only doing the right thing just because
it's not against the law or the only
thing not against the law I think I'd
rather people are motivated to help the
community and get involved and when
doing things like that I really don't
want to have anything get in the way you
know it's those are the kind of
scenarios where I feel like I just want
to like if we can pave the road as much
and as far as possible and then hope we
can build a community around this and an
ecosystem where people want to do good
to the people around them but I realize
there'll be cases where people might
fall through the cracks and it might be
a little bit more ideological that's
what I shoot for or strive for all right
well I always ask my guests to give us a
little bit of their personal story and
you've talked a little bit about what
you've done
prior to this with your doctoral work
and a little bit about the residency
program but give us a little more
context on your background where you're
from and how you ended up in the
Microsoft AI residency program so
sometimes it's funny looking back things
can seem a little bit arbitrary I mean I
grew up on a dairy farm in Minnesota I
wasn't sure if I wanted to go to college
or not
but other people seem to be and I and
then another wrestling coach is
recruiting me so that made it easy then
I got an academic fluoride which also
made it easier so I decided to go for my
bachelor's in math then I was planning
on going back and teaching high school
math and coaching wrestling and I had
taken a couple computer science classes
I took like the intro course in a data
structures course in programming
languages course and then found out
there'd been a few professors in
undergrad who had asked like why I
wasn't planning on going for like my PhD
or going to grad school or anything like
that and I always said that I didn't
want to invest any more money in an
education if I didn't see how it would
pay out so I was a bit more I guess
pragmatic perhaps given my background
and a lack of exposure to those kind of
things before but then my senior year
one of the professor's was asking him in
more detail about why I don't want to go
and stuff and then when I mentioned that
I didn't want to invest more money in an
education if I didn't see necessarily
the payout she said that a lot of PhD
programs are covered and you can get a
like a stipend on top of it and and then
I figured I might as well apply yeah so
I had enjoyed doing stuff with computer
science so I thought I would apply to
computer science PhD programs even
though I didn't major a minor in it and
then I actually heard about the
Microsoft AI residency while
interviewing on site for the Google AI
residency oh really and then came back
and applied to this one so sometimes
it's funny looking back because
sometimes the path to get here can seem
pretty arbitrary definitely but I'm
excited to be here well on the heels of
that question my new favorite one is the
one I'm gonna ask you next what's one
interesting thing about you that we
couldn't find on a web search maybe that
has influenced your career hmm so I mean
I bring up wrestling the one I was
student teaching and running deck
studies the students like to Google me
and find pictures of me wrestling and
instead it is like their background or
incorporated into their games so you can
definitely find that on a web search but
it's hard to really give enough credit
to some of the experiences that you can
have that really play a role in your
career development like although being a
dairy farmer growing up on a dairy farm
doesn't really seem to be maybe most
closely related doing research in AI and
machine learning I think there certainly
a lot of different attitudes and
perspectives that can be really positive
and and I think that in some ways it can
keep me very pragmatic in the sense that
I really like seeing some like outcome
or the benefit of what I'm working on
and I think in those ways like being
able to work with kids and just trying
to help give them all the tools to be
able to succeed
regardless of background it's something
that can have some sort of positive
impact and I think that some of the
experiences and the pragmatic nature
growing up on a farm played a little bit
of an influence and keeping me grounded
that way my husband's father used to say
cows never go on vacation that's true my
my wife and I have been together for 12
years basically I got a driver's license
and a girlfriend like when we were
dating a lot of times it was hard for me
to get out of chores and things like
that so we spent a lot of dates milking
cows and some feeding cows and things
all sorts of things like that Brian this
has been so much fun
as we close you're much closer to the
beginning of your career than many of
the guests I've had on the show so I
want to put a little different spin on
the what advice would you give to
emerging researchers because you're kind
of one yeah and I'll simply ask you
what's next for dr. Brian Broll yeah so
I'm going to be a research scientist at
Vanderbilt starting in September and
I'll be continuing some of the work
tried to increase the impact of some of
the work that I did during my PhD as
well as explore ways that we can try to
make deep learning more accessible
especially to people in the Natural
Sciences so I'll be working on those
immediate projects but I'm definitely
interested in seeing other ways that we
can try to combine some of my experience
here we're getting more involved with AI
and machine learning with some of the
perspectives and kind of driving ideas
that I've had throughout grad school and
about trying to make these tools more
powerful and accessible so that
hopefully we can have a bigger impact
more broadly so let me ask you a
question I was going to ask before but I
really do want to hear it what you think
what was your favorite thing about the
residency program and what would you
advise people that might be interested
in ending up at Microsoft's AI residency
program so my favorite thing is probably
the
like diversity of research projects that
are out there and being able to work so
closely with so many very impressive
researchers in so many different areas I
think it's really great to be able to
have that sort of exposure especially
when you're trying to learn more about
different aspects of AI and machine
learning it's really hard to replace
being able to work so closely with so
many different researchers here at MSR
Brian Grohl thank you for joining us
today it's been illuminating and
delightful things it's been a pleasure
[Music]
to learn more about academic programs
with Microsoft Research visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]